♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE FBI'S HANDLING
OF THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION IS INCREASINGLY
LOOKING CORRUPT.
THAT'S WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS
SHOWING.
LISA PAGE, WHERE DATING ONE
ANOTHER, SUGGEST THE BUREAU FELT
"PRESSURE" TO WRAP UP THAT
INVESTIGATION AND EXONERATE HER
EVEN BEFORE THEY HAD INTERVIEWED
HER.
WE COULD LEARN MORE BUT THE FBI
SAYS IT HAS LOST THOUSANDS OF
MESSAGES, TEXT MESSAGES, SENT
BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE.
KNOW ANY OF THIS IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU REMEMBER, OF COURSE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH
SAID SHE WOULD ACCEPT WHATEVER
THE FBI'S RECOMMENDATION WAS IN
THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
NOW IT LOOKS FROM THESE TEXTS
THAT SHE HAD ALREADY DECIDED TO
EXONERATE HILLARY CLINTON.
>> SHE ALREADY KNEW THAT COMEY
WAS GOING TO RECOMMEND
EXONERATION.
>> THAT STRIKES ME IS THE
DEFINITION OF CORRUPTION, AM I
MISSING SOMETHING?
>> NOT AT ALL.
WHAT'S MAKING A LOT OF NEWS IS
THE FIVE MONTHS OF MIXING TEXT
MESSAGES WHICH WE WILL CONTINUE
TO INVESTIGATE OURSELVES.
THE FACT THAT LORETTA LYNCH KNEW
BEFORE SHE MADE THE BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT BECAUSE OF
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS OF INTEREST,
MEANING BILL CLINTON, I WILL LET
JAMES COMEY DECIDE THAT.
COMBINED WITH ALL THE EDITING OF
THAT MEMO, THE PRODUCTION OF
THAT THING BEGAN TWO MONTHS
BEFORE THEY ACTUALLY INTERVIEWED
SECRETARY CLINTON, THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A PROBLEM.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
INDICATE A DEEP-SEATED
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE FBI.
I'VE GOT TO SAY THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FBI FOLKS ARE
HIGH INTEGRITY AND THEY ARE
RISKING THEIR LIVES TO KEEP US
SAFE, BUT AT THE UPPER LEVEL
WHAT WE ARE STARTING TO UNCOVER
IS JUST A LEVEL OF CORRUPTION
THAT NEEDS FURTHER
INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: LISA PAGE, FBI
EMPLOYEE SAYS LORETTA LYNCH
KNOWS NO CHARGES WILL BE BROUGHT
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON.
IT WOULDN'T BE WORTH SPEAKING TO
FORMER AGENT PAGE, I BELIEVE SHE
STILL WORKS THERE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO TRY AND
RECOVER THOSE FIVE MONTHS WORTH
OF EMAIL, OR TEXTS BECAUSE
THAT'S A PRETTY CRUCIAL TIME
BETWEEN DECEMBER OF 2016 AND
MAY.
A LOT WAS GOING DOWN IN TERMS OF
THE FBI INVESTIGATION UNDER THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE JUST LOST
SOMEHOW.
THEY ARE BLAMING THE TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY.
HOW OFTEN OUR PEOPLES' TAX LIENS
WE BETTER GET A GOOD TAX
ATTORNEY OR A GOOD ATTORNEY IN
SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM.
WHEN THEY LOSE, A LITTLE
TECHNOLOGY BELOW.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
WE ARE GOING TO WORRY ABOUT IT,
WE WILL KEEP DIGGING.
>> Tucker: THE IDEA IS THAT
THEY HAD THESE TEXTS IN THEIR
POSSESSION AND THEY LOST THEM
SOMEHOW.
>> THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
PRESERVED.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY DIDN'T
PRESERVE THEM.
THE GOOD NEWS IS, THESE
TECHNOLOGY TEXTS GO UP TO SOME
SERVER, SOME CLOUD.
THEY ARE PROBABLY STORED
SOMEWHERE, WHICH IS WHY WE WILL
PROBABLY BE RELEASING, OR
CERTAINLY LOOKING AT
PRESERVATION RECORD LETTERS TO
SOME OF THESE TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES.
>> Tucker: WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO SUBPOENA THE
>> PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO DO
HOPEFULLY WON'T HAVE TO
WON'T.
>> SHE HAS NOT RESPONDED.
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT SHE HAS
TO SAY, INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
DIRECTOR COMEY HAS TO SAY AS
WELL.
HE TESTIFIED AT SOMEONE VARIANCE